BENEFITS FOR THE RETIRED
EMPLOYEES.
A BIRD AND THAT COSTS
$5.5 BILLION PER YEAR, BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
FACEBOOK SHARES WERE UP AFTER
MARK ZUCKERBERG SUBBED THE
PRIVACY DATA SCANDAL HAS HAD NO
MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON USAGE OR
AD SALES.
CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG IS ABOUT TO
COME TO CAPITOL HILL TO EXPLAIN
HIMSELF.
TONIGHT CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL SETS
THE STAGE AND EXPLORES WHAT
CONGRESSIONAL REGULATION THE
FACEBOOK MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
>> AHEAD OF HIS APPEARANCE IN
FRONT OF KEY CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES OF THE HOUSE AND
SENATE NEXT WEEK, FACEBOOK CEO
MARK ZUCKERBERG HAS ALREADY
STARTED HIS APOLOGY TOUR.
>> WE NEED TO FOCUS ENOUGH ON
SEEING HOW PEOPLE CAN USE THESE
TOOLS FOR ARM, FAKE NEWS, HATE
SPEECH.
IN ADDITION TO DEVELOPERS AND
DATA PRIVACY.
WE DID NOT TAKE A BROADER NEPHEW
OF WHAT OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
AND THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
IT WAS MY MISTAKE.
IT'S BECAUSE A COMPANY'S CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER IS
TELEGRAPHING WHAT CONGRESS
MIGHT HEAR.
>> WE ARE FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFTING
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT THIS.
WE ARE NO LONGER JUST TRYING TO
BUILD THE SOCIAL EXPERIENCES.
WE ALWAYS WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
PRIVACY BUT NOT ENOUGH.
WE ARE ALSO TAKING MORE
PROACTIVE STEPS TO GET AHEAD OF
A POSSIBLE MISUSE.
>> FACEBOOK IS IN HOT WATER
AFTER ALLEGATIONS CAMBRIDGE ENDO
ATTICA MISUSED DATA OF
87 MILLION USERS.
THE FIGURE IS ROUGHLY THE
COMBINED POPULATIONS OF
NEW YORK, TEXAS, AND CALIFORNIA.
AND AMY KLOBUCHAR BOTH HAVE A
CHANCE TO QUESTION SUB OR DON
MARK ZUCKERBERG SIGNALED HER
APPROACH.
"I EXPECT TO ASK HIM WHAT HE IS
DOING TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
AMERICANS AND HOW HE WILL
ADDRESSES SIGNIFICANT BREACHES
OF PRIVACY AND TRUST THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE LAST YEAR."
CHUCK GRASSLEY SAYS USERS
DESERVE TO KNOW HOW THEIR
INFORMATION IS SHARED AND
SECURED.
SENATE COMMERCE CHAIRMAN
REPUBLICAN JOHN THUNE SAYS THE
REVELATIONS HAVE GENERATED
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN ABOUT
FACEBOOK'S ROLE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
FACEBOOK'S ROLE IN OUR DEMOCRAC
DEMOCRACY.
CONGRESSIONAL SOURCES SAY THESE
HEARINGS WILL BE THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD INCREASED SCRUTINY OVER
THE TAX INDUSTRY, WITH A